[Music]
in today's eight on your side you're
vaccinated you're ready to travel but
which cities offer the most paying for
your buck while keeping you safe
a recent study ranking the best cities
for your summer vaccation that's a
vaccine for
that's a vacation excuse me for the
covert vaccinated compared the 200
biggest u.s cities based on 30
indicators of a fun and a safe excursion
san francisco came in first followed by
portland oregon providence rhode island
rounding out the top
three you can see the rest of the list
here las vegas made the list at number
nine
the study looked at everything from
walkability reviews from hotels airbnb
rentals climate lounges cocktail bars as
well as vaccination rates and safety
if you're going someplace where you
really want to be safe
go someplace where it's smaller maybe
think outside the traditional
travel getaway box don't go to those
tourist things don't go to those theme
parks
but maybe take a canoe ride with your
family because
the thing to consider now is it's not
just you if you have children
your children may not be vaccinated yet
so
you have to be able to find a way to
keep them safe
while you're having fun as a family all
right the three worst cities for your
summer vaccation according to this
survey included two places in our state
as well
sunrise manor and enterprise as well as
grand prairie texas
well you can't have it all right
christian but las vegas has so much to
offer i mean why not
of course it should be moved up to that
one of maybe the top three on that list
we can wish